ALLEN ARCHULETA ATKINS BAKER
GORGEOUS BRADFORD CABALLERO
PORTENDING DALLY DODD TORONTO
EGGMAN GROVE HERTZBERG HUESO
HURTADO JONES LAYERED LEYVA
MCGUIRE MELENDEZ MEN NEWMAN
NIELSEN- CHAU OF VOGUE. PAN
PORTANTINO ROB RUBIO SKINNER
NUMBER WHITE HOUSE SKI WIENER
WILK. GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS.
WHAT THE MEMBERS IN OUR GUESTS
OH I'M SORRY WE NEED TO CALL ON
OUR MEMBERS WHO ARE PRESENT WHO
ARE WITH US REMOTELY MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
MEMBERS. BATES BATES HERE.
GLAZER. GLAZER. SENATOR YOU'RE
ON MUTE. YOU GUYS ARE
CONTROLLING THE MUSIC SENATOR
GLAZER HERE THANK YOU. GONZALEZ
SENATOR GONZALEZ HERE. LIMóN
AND THAT EARLY MOUNT HERE.
STERN. BETTER STERN HERE.
EXCELLENT. THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY WITH THE MEMBERS AND
OUR GUESTS BEYOND THE RAIL AND
IN THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE WILL
BE LED IN PRAYER THIS AFTERNOON
BY SENATOR- CHOI BOGUE AFTER
WHICH PLEASE REMAIN STANDING
WILL BE LED IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG BY
SENATOR ARCHULETA SENATOR A
TROUBLED. SENATE PRAYER FOR
JANUARY ELEVENTH TWO THOUSAND
AND TWENTY ONE. GOD OF LOVE
TRUTH AND PEACEFULNESS AS WE
MOVE INTO THIS NEW CALENDAR
YEAR WE ARE KEENLY AWARE THAT
THE ROAD AHEAD IS FOR ROAD. THE
WAY SPRINKLED AND RUMBLED
SCATTERED WITH DEBRIS. THIS IS
THE ROAD OUR ANCESTORS WALKED.
THE RUINS CHANGE BUT THE PATH
REMAINS THE SAME. THEREFORE WE
WILL WALK GENTLY WE WILL WALK
FOR THE SAKE OF OTHERS KNOWING
HE WALKED BESIDE US. EVEN THE
UNSEEN PATHS BEFORE US HAVE
BEEN WALK BEFORE. IN ALL ITS
WONDERING IT UNKNOWNS WE TRUST
THAT THE ROAD AHEAD IS HELD IN
THE PALM OF YOUR HAND. SO WE
WERE WALKING PIECE KNOWING
EVERY STEP EVEN OUR MISSTEPS AS
WE FIND A WAY FOR ALWAYS BLAST.
ALWAYS ACCOMPANIED ALWAYS THE
JOURNEY HOME AMEN. PLEASE DON'T
PLACE YOUR HAND OVER YOUR HEART
AS WE HONOR OUR FLAG OF MEN AND
WOMEN WHO SERVED OUR GREAT
COUNTRY OUR FIRST RESPONDERS WE
DEDICATE THIS TO YOU. I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS AND HAPPY NEW
YEAR PLEASE BE SEATED. TODAY AS
YOU NOTED WE HAVE SENATORS
BATES GLAZER GONZALEZ RAMON AND
STERN PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
GOOD AFTERNOON SENATORS WE
WELCOME YOU AS WELL MEMBERS
THE NEXT ORDER OF BUSINESS IS
REMARKS BY THE PRESIDENT PRO
TEM CENTER ATKINS FULL BY
REMARKS BY THE REPUBLICAN
LEADER SENATOR GROWTH SENATOR
ATKINS. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT GOOD AFTERNOON AND
COLLEAGUES WELCOME BACK TO EACH
AND EVERYONE OF YOU. WE RETURN
TODAY TO CONTINUE THE PEOPLE'S
BUSINESS IN THE STATE CAPITAL
THAT IS NOT ONLY A SYMBOL OF
THE LAWS OF THE INSTITUTIONS
THAT HOLD US TOGETHER AS
SOCIETY. BUT ALSO WORKING AS A
LABORATORY TO BRING ABOUT
PROGRESS AND JUSTICE. I KNOW
THAT WE ALL WATCHED IN
DISBELIEF SHOCK AND ANGER WHEN
OUR NATION'S CAPITAL WAS
ATTACKED LAST WEEK. AND THERE
ARE CONVERSATIONS THAT NEED TO
BE HAD AND ACTIONS THAT NEED TO
BE TAKEN REGARDING THAT ATTACK
AND FORCES BEHIND IT. AND THERE
WILL BE TIME AHEAD FOR THE
NATION TO TALK ABOUT THAT IN
FACT I HAVE NO DOUBT THAT WE
WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO. BUT
TODAY TODAY. WE BEST RESPECT
OUR CONSTITUENTS AND THE
CONSTITUTION. BY MOVING FORWARD
WITH THE PEOPLE'S BUSINESS.
NORMALLY IF THAT WORD EVEN
EXIST ANYMORE. JANUARY IS A
RELATIVELY QUIET MONTH ON OUR
LEGISLATIVE CALENDAR. THIS YEAR
AGO WITH SO MANY CALIFORNIANS
CONTINUING TO STRUGGLE THROUGH
THIS PANDEMIC WE WILL BE
WORKING TO TAKE EARLY ACTIONS
ON THE BUDGET TO HELP SMALL
BUSINESSES. RENTERS LANDLORDS
SCHOOLS OTHERS WHO NEED
ECONOMIC RELIEF AND TO DO
EVERYTHING IN OUR COLLECTIVE
POWERS TO GET THE COVERT
VACCINE DISTRIBUTED THROUGHOUT
OUR STATE. I WANT TO TAKE A
MINUTE TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND THANK
OUR COLLEAGUE FROM BERKELEY FOR
STEPPING UP AND ACCEPTING THE
CHALLENGE OF SERVING AS BUDGET
CHAIR IN THESE DIFFICULT TIMES.
AS WE DO OUR WORK PLEASE KNOW
THAT SECRETARY CONTRARIUS AND
CHIEF SERGEANT RODRIGUEZ ARE
DOING THEIR WORK TO ENSURE THE
SAFETY AND THE SECURITY OF THE
CAPITAL. AND ALL OF US WHO WORK
HERE. THAT INCLUDED HEARING TO
THE LATEST PROTOCOLS FOR
PREVENTING THE SPREAD OF COVE
IN NINETEEN. SHOULD ADDITIONAL
PREVENTION EFFORTS ARE
PROTOCOLS REQUIRE CHANGES IN
HOW WE OPERATE. WE WILL OF
COURSE KEEP YOU AND YOUR STAFF
UP TO DATE. WE SHOULD ALL
REMAIN FLEXIBLE AND I HOPE
REMAIN GOOD EXAMPLES FOR THE
PEOPLE WE SERVE. BY FOLLOWING
THE SCIENCE IN STOPPING THE
SPREAD AND BEING KIND TO EACH
OTHER LET ME JUST ADD THAT AS
MY OWN. COMMENT THANK YOU FOR A
FEW MINUTES TO WELL WELCOME AND
OPEN. AND WITH YOUR PERMISSION
AS YOU STATED ALREADY I KNOW
THE REPUBLICAN LEADER HAS A FEW
OPENING COMMENTS AS WELL. THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES THANK YOU SIR
ATKINS. CENTER GROVE. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I JOIN THE
SENATE PRO TEM AND WELCOMING
ALL OF YOU BACK- TO THE SENATE
CHAMBER SO THAT WE CAN START
ADDRESSING THE PEOPLE'S
BUSINESS. LIKE THE SENATE PRO
TEM MENTIONED BRIEFLY THE
ATTACK ON OUR CAPITOL IN
WASHINGTON DC WAS UNTENABLE WE
IT WAS JUST AN ACCEPTABLE. AND
IT IS NOT A PATRIOT ACTS LIKE
THAT. ARROGANCE WE CAN OFTEN
DISAGREED DEBATE FORMULATOR
OPINIONS BUT WE SHOULD NEVER.
EVER RESULT TO VIOLENCE. SO
TODAY WE START A NEW
LEGISLATIVE SESSION AND WE'RE
JOINED ON THIS FLOOR- TO SERVE.
AS REPRESENTATIVES OF FORTY
MILLION PEOPLE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHO ARE HURTING. OUR
GOLDEN STATE IS THEIR HOME AND
THEY NEED OUR HELP MORE THAN
EVER BEFORE. NEVER BEFORE HAVE
WE BEEN PRESENTED WITH
ADDRESSING SO MANY ISSUES THAT
WE ARE HERE TODAY. NEARLY HALF
THE NATION'S AND SHELTERED
POPULATION RESIDE IN OUR STATE
OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM IS A
FALLING IF FAILING LEAVING
STUDENTS FAR BEHIND IN THEIR
STUDIES AND STRUGGLING WITH
MENTAL HEALTH. ISSUES AS A
RESULT OF THE PANDEMIC.
CALIFORNIANS ARE ISOLATED THERE
ALONE THEY'RE BATTLING BOTH
SUBSTANCE ABUSE MENTAL HEALTH
COMPLICATIONS AT ALARMING
RATES. BUSINESSES ARE CLOSING
THEIR DOORS FOR GOOD IN
CALIFORNIANS UNEMPLOYED ARE
STRUGGLING TO COMPETE FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS WITH
PRISONERS THEY DON'T DESERVE
THOSE BENEFITS AND ALSO PEOPLE
FROM OUT OF STATE. AND WE
ESPECIALLY. THATTODAY A LOT OF
US ARE WEARING BLUE AND THE
NATIONAL HUMAN TRAFFICKING
AWARENESS DAY AND THAT REPORTS
HAVE INDICATED THAT BECAUSE OF
THE PANDEMIC IT'S LED TO RISING
HUMAN TRAFFICKING. IT'S OUR
HONOR AND A PRIVILEGE TO SERVE
IN THIS CHAMBER BESIDE EACH ONE
OF YOU. IN THAT WE ARE GOING TO
WORK HARD ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER ALONG
WITH. ALL OF US IN THE OTHER
HOUSES WELL TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE BETTER CALIFORNIANS LIVES.
WE'VE GOT TO WORK TO RESTORE
CALIFORNIA'S PROMISE BY
PROTECTING FAMILIES AND
CHILDREN IN STRENGTHENING
OPPORTUNITIES AND PREPARE IN
REPAIRING TRASHED. IN THEIR IN
THE PEOPLE'S GOVERNMENT WE HAVE
A LOT OF WORK TO DO IT SOME
TIME TO GET STARTED AND I
WELCOME YOU ALL BACK TO THIS
TWENTY TWENTY ONE LEGISLATIVE
SESSION. THANK YOU SENATOR GROW.
SUCH AS FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ MESSAGES FROM
THE ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED
READ. REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ.
INTRODUCTION AND FIRST BILL
READING OF BILLS WILL ALSO BE
DEEMED READ. MEMBERS THE NEXT-ORDER OF BUSINESS WILL BE
SENATE RESOLUTION THREE BY
SENATOR ACTIONS RELATIVE TO THE
STANDING RULES OF THE SENATE
FULL BY SENATE RESOLUTION FOR.
BY CENTER HERTZBERG RELATIVE TO
THE ELECTION OF COMMITTEES OF
THE COMMITTEE ON RULES.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
RESOLUTION THREE. SENATE
RESOLUTION THREE BY SENATOR
ATKINS RELATIVE TO THE STANDING
RULES OF THE SENATE FOR THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
REGULAR SESSION. THE NEW ATKINS
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
SENATE RESOLUTION THREE WILL
DOT THE SENATE RULES FOR THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
SESSION THE RULES ARE PRIMARILY
THE SAME AS LAST SESSION BUT
THEY DO REFLECT SOME LESSONS
LEARNED AS WE NAVIGATE THE
COVERT NINETEEN CRISIS. WE NEED
TO BE ABLE TO CONDUCT OUR
BUSINESS AS CLOSE AS POSSIBLE
TO THE WAY THE SENATE HAS
TRADITIONALLY OPERATED. BUT WE
HAVE TO FACE THE REALITY THAT
SOMETIMES MODIFICATIONS ARE
NEEDED. YOU CAN SEE THAT JUST
BY LOOKING AROUND OF COURSE THE
ROOM WE ARE IN TODAY. SO PLEASE
JOIN ME IN ADOPTING SENATE
RESOLUTION THREE TO ALLOW US TO
DO THIS AND IT'S IMPORTANT
BUSINESS FOR THE NEW SESSION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER ATKINS MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE
SENATOR NIELSEN. MADAM
PRESIDENT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
THE SENATE. THIS IS THE FIRST
TIME IN ALL OF MY YEARS THAT I
WILL NOT VOTE. FOR RULES. I
WILL ABSTAIN I DON'T TEND TO
VOTE NO. BUT THESE I CONSIDER
PRETTY EGREGIOUS DEPARTURE. OF
THE HISTORIC TRADITIONS OF THIS
HONORABLE HOUSE. AND THEY
AGREED. BOTH REPUBLICAN AND
DEMOCRAT MEMBERS OF THIS HOUSE.
THEY ARE A DELIBERATE ATEMPT
TO CONSTRAIN THE BAIT. WITH
VERY BROAD PARAMETERS. AND
PARAMETERS RATHER OF HOW THAT
COULD HAPPEN. ALL THE GUYS OF
COAL THAT. THAT'S NOT THE ISSUE
COVERED IT'S IRRELEVANT IT IS
AN EXCUSE. BUT HE'S
COMPROMISING OF THE RULES. AND
IF IT IS SO IMPORTANT WHERE THE
NOT NAY. THE SUNSET. THIS CALL
WOULD THINK COULD END SOMETIME
THIS YEAR WHY WOULD WE WANT TO
OPERATE UNDER THESE RULES. WHEN
THAT. FEAR IS EXTINGUISHED.
AGAIN WE SAW SOME OF THIS.
TOWARD THE END OF LAST
RECESSION. LIMITING THE
PARTICIPATION OF MEMBERS. EVEN
CUTTING OFF THE MICROPHONES
MEMBERS OF THE MINORITY PARTY
WHO ARE REMOTING IN NOW THAT
DOES NOT BE SUGGESTED HERE. BUT
THE VERY EXPLICIT RESTRICTIONS
ON THE BAIT. THIS IS CONFIRMED
IT. CONTAINED IN HERE IS
OWNERS. AND TO CHARACTERIZE
THIS. AS CO DEFINED CODIFYING
SENATE PRESIDENT IS A RONI US
THIS IS NOT SENATE PRESIDENT
FORMER MEMBERS OF THIS
HONORABLE INSTITUTION THROUGH
THE DECADES THAT I HAVE SERVED
WHAT ABSOLUTELY BE INFURIATED
BY THIS. AND I WOULD THINK THAT
THE PRESS SHOULD BE CONCERNED
AND MOST ASSUREDLY THE CITIZENS
THAT WE REPRESENT. WE'RE NOT
HERE EVERY DAY WHO MAYBE ONLY A
REGULAR EVEN WATCH ANYTHING ON
TV. BUT THIS IS NOT THE SENATE
POSITIONED TO BE CONSTRAINED IN
YOUR DEBATE. WE ARE ALWAYS
RESPECTFUL IN OUR DEBATE. AND
RESPECTFUL OF THE TIME OF OTHER
MEMBERS. BUT I PARTICULARLY
CONSIDERED REPREHENSIBLE TO SAY
IT'S AN EXCUSE IF WE HAVE TOO
MANY BILLS AT THE END OF
SESSION THAT IS A PRODUCT OF
NEGLIGENCE. OF EITHER HOUSE
THROUGH THE COURSE OF THE YEAR
TO MOVE THEIR BILL- TOMORROW.
HAVE COMMITTEE HEARINGS. AND IT
IS ALSO A CONVENIENT WAY FOR
GAME PLAYERS THE MIDSHIPMEN
APPEAL LIKE THE END OF SESSION.
UNFORTUNATELY A FEW YEARS AGO
THE CITIZENSHIP INTO THEIR OWN
HANDS THE SEVENTY TWO HOUR RULE.
THE LEGISLATURE NEVER RESPONDED
OVER DECADES TO THAT EITHER.
AND HERE IS BUT ANOTHER EXAMPLE.
IT IS A TERRIBLE WAY LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN OF THE SENATE TO
BEGIN OUR YEAR. TO BE A
TERRIBLE WAY. TO FINISH OUR
YEAR AS WAS THE END OF LAST
YEAR I URGE AN ABSTENTION OR NO
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR NELSON
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE- CENTER WILL MEMBERS-
THERE'S A LITTLE BLAIR ON SOME
OF THE FIELDS THE SO I
APOLOGIZE IF I'M NOT INTENSELY
TRYING TO MISS ANYONE RIGHT NOW
TO PRESENT I JUST PUT IT UP SO
YOU'RE FORGIVEN- I RISE. IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE AS
VICE CHAIR OF RULES COMMITTEE-
WEEKS BEFORE WE WERE TO CONVENE
THIS NEW SESSION I ASKED TO SEE
A COPY OF THE RULES. AND I WAS
TOLD THAT THE PROTEIN IS GOING
THROUGH THEM AND I WOULD GET IT
AN APPROPRIATE TIME.
HISTORICALLY I BELIEVE WE'VE
ALWAYS ADOPTED THEM ON ON THE
ON THE FIRST DAY LEGISLATIVE
SESSION SO I CONTINUE TO ASK. I
GOT MY COPY AT AT ONE PM TODAY-
AND I JUST DON'T FEEL LIKE
THAT'S APPROPRIATE I ECHO
EVERYTHING THAT- MY STEAM
CALLING THE DEAN OF THE SENATE-
UTTERED. BUT FOR ME IF WE WANT
TO HAVE A VIBRANT. DEMOCRACY WE
HAVE TO HAVE TRANSPARENCY. IN
THESE ROLES I DON'T LIKE HIM.
BUT WE SHOULD BE FAIR ABOUT IT.
EVERYBODY SHOULD HAVE IT IN
ADVANCE NOTICE AND WE SHOULD
HAVE A RIGOROUS DEBATE ABOUT IT
YOU HAVE THE VOTES THERE'S NO
THERE'S NO REASON. TO DO IT
THIS WAY SO YOUR SHAME ON YOU
FOR THIS LACK OF TRANSPARENCY
WE'RE NOT OFF TO. WE ARE NOT
OFF TO A GOOD START. AND I
THINK I'M A PERSON OF GOODWILL.
AND I TRY TO WORK ACROSS THE
AISLE WITH THIS FRANKLY IT'S IF
IT'S OFFENSIVE. IT'S OFFENSIVE
THE WAY YOU'RE DOING IT AND- I
HOPE WE CAN DO BETTER MOVING
FORWARD AND I ASK FOR NO VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR WELCOME. TO
GO REMOTELY TO SENATOR STERN
WHO HAS. HIS HAND UP SENATOR
STERN. CENTER IF YOU IDENTIFY
YOURSELF AND THEN START
SPEAKING. AS SENATOR HENRY
STERN IN THE TWENTY SEVENTH
DISTRICT- THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT FOR THE RECOGNITION-
I. I CAN'T RISE I GUESS I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE- YOU
KNOW I'M WE TALK ABOUT PROCESS
AND BEING DENIED- CERTAIN
RIGHTS AND OPPORTUNITIES I
CONSIDER TODAY'S REMOTE
PARTICIPATION AND FRANKLY THE
INABILITY TO CAST A FLOOR VOTE
HERE. IN AN AMBITION OF MY OWN
ABILITY TO REPRESENT MY
CONSTITUENTS BECAUSE OF A LACK
OF TRUST FRANKLY YOU KNOW HOW
THESE CHAMBERS HAVE BEEN
TREATED NOW THIS BODIES BEEN
TREATED AT THE END OF SESSION
LAST YEAR WE SAW IT IN STARK
RELIEF. AND THAT WAS THE LACK
OF. COMITY THAT TRADITION OF
THE SENATE. IN LOOKING OUT FOR
YOUR FELLOW MEMBERS IN
CONDUCTING YOURSELF IN WALKING
GENTLY AS OUR OPENING PRAYER
PUT IT- WALKING GENTLY IN THIS
MOMENT AND HOW YOU CONDUCT
YOURSELF. AND HOW YOU WOULD
HEAR TO BASIC PUBLIC HEALTH
PROTOCOLS. NOW YOU CAN GET
YOURSELF IN THESE CHAMBERS AND
FRANKLY AND HOW YOU CONDUCT
YOURSELF IN DEBATE. WHEN YOU
YOURSELF IS X. OF EXPOSED THE
BODY AND OTHER MEMBERS. TO THIS
VIRUS- ANY OTHER ACCOMMODATED
TO PARTICIPATE AND ACTUALLY
VOTE IN THE PROCESS. DESPITE
THAT EXPOSURE. AND TO UTILIZE
AN EXPLOIT THAT PROCESS TO COME
UP THE GEARS OF DEMOCRACY TO ME
THAT'S THAT'S THE DEEPER
OFFENSE. I DON'T WANT TO RE
LITIGATE THE PAST AND MAKE
TODAY ABOUT A RETROSPECTIVE-
BUT I CONSIDER THESE RULES A
CRITICAL PIECE OF MOVING
FORWARD. WE CAN'T AFFORD TO
OPERATE AS A BODY IT IS ON
FACEBOOK LIVE WHILE WE'RE
SITTING HERE ON A REMOTE TO.
USING THIS IS A POLITICAL
GRANDSTANDING. GOING TO TALK
ABOUT PEACE AND WALKING GENTLY
LET'S SHOW. THE SEATED AT PEACE
I SEE HER TODAY THE PART OF THE
REASON I'M NOT UP THERE.
PARTICIPATING IN THE
SENSITIVITY MY FAMILY. YEAH I'M
I'M LEGISLATING BUT I'M CARE
TAKING TO. YOU KNOW WHAT I MY
WIFE AND I ARE DEALING WITH
CHALLENGES IN THAT REGARD THAT
MANY OTHER PEOPLE ARE AROUND
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA BUT
LIFE AND DEATH EVERYDAY
CHALLENGES. EMILY IN A NURSING
HOME. AND CARE TAKING FOR
NINETY THREE YEAR OLD MAN EVERY
SINGLE DAY. AND I DIDN'T FEEL
IT PRUDENT. TO COME INTO THOSE
CHAMBERS WITHOUT SOME
ASSURANCES LIKE WE HAVE IN
THESE ROLES HERE TODAY. IT
PROTOCOLS AND PRACTICES WE'RE
GOING TO BE. CARRIED OUT AND
ENFORCED. BY OUR LEADERSHIP WE
WERE BUILT ON- SOME KIND OF
SIMILAR TO TRUST THAT TO ME WAS
ERODED SO IRREPARABLE THE AT
THE END OF LAST SESSION WE NEED
ACTION LIKE THIS TODAY TO
FORMALIZE IT I WILL SAY THOSE
SEEDS OF HOPE AS I MENTIONED
ARE THERE. I'VE HEARD THAT
THERE'S- UNIFORMITY HEARINGS TO
OUR TESTING PROTOCOLS IS THE
REPORTS THAT- I UNDERSTAND THAT
EVERYONE ON THE FLOOR AS AS
PARTICIPATING IN AN EXERCISE
AND THAT IS AN INCREDIBLY GOOD
SIGN- BUT- I DON'T THINK WE CAN
AFFORD TO JUST GO ON WORD ALONE
ANYMORE THAT'S WHY I'M GONNA BE
VOTING. I IN SUPPORT OF THESE
ROLE CHANGES HERE TODAY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR STERN
SENATOR BORDERS. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT. LIKE MANY OF
YOU I AD TO TRAVEL TO GET
SACRAMENTO TODAY. AND MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT. MY
OFFICE LIKE MANY OTHERS GOT A
COPY OF THIS. AFTER TWELVE
THIRTY THIS AFTERNOON I CAME
INTO MY OFFICE BUT SEVEN TO TEN
MINUTES BEFORE TWO O'CLOCK. I
DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT THIS
DOCUMENT SAYS. AND IT'S NOT A
SIMPLE DOCUMENT IT IS DOCUMENT
WITHIN. SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
PROCEDURAL CHANGES TO OR OR
RULES AND I THINK THERE'S ABOUT
FORTY PAGES HERE AND I THINK-
ALL OF ITS RELEVANT. NOT JUST
THE SUMMARY SO- I'M NOT
NECESSARILY TAKING A SIDE ON
WHETHER THESE THINGS ARE
APPROPRIATE MY- COLLEAGUE FROM-
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA JUST BROKE
A MOMENT AGO SAYING IT'S NEEDED
MY COLLEAGUE- ON THE REPUBLICAN
SIDE. AND SAID THAT IT IS A
DEVIATION A PAST PRACTICE AND
PRECEDENT. TO BE HONEST I DON'T
EVEN KNOW. SO I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT WE AT
LEAST CONSIDER MAYBE BRING THIS
ITEM BACK ON FRIDAY WHEN WE
HAVE FLOOR SESSION NEXT AS A
POSSIBILITY FOR US TO BETTER
APPRECIATE THE TERMS AND
PROVISIONS OF THIS ACTION ITEM.
BUT WITHOUT THAT I'LL BE
CASTING. A NOTE IN ITS TENSION
VOTERS SIMPLY BECAUSE I DON'T
EVEN KNOW WHAT'S IN IT. THANK
YOU SENATOR BORDERS SENATOR
WIENER. I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR PRESIDENT I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THESE RULES AND WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THESE RULES WHICH
FLOW DIRECTLY FROM THE COVETING
THAT WE HAD TO DO LAST YEAR
THESE RULES ARE FUNDAMENTALLY
ABOUT PUBLIC HEALTH. AND WE HAD
TO CHANGE HOW WE DID HOW WE
OPERATED LAST YEAR SORT OF THE
ASSEMBLY. BECAUSE OF THIS
PANDEMIC. AND WE INSTITUTED A
NUMBER OF NEW APPROACHES- SOME
OF WHICH ARE NOW BEING
CODIFIED. IN THESE RULES THESE
RULES SPECIFICALLY GIVE THE
PROTON THE ABILITY. TO REQUIRE
CERTAIN BEHAVIORS AS A MATTER
OF PUBLIC HEALTH LIKE WEARING
MASKS. FIVE THESE ARE OUR RULES
WILL MAKE CLEAR- THAT WE HAVE
FLEXIBILITY WITH COMMITTEE
MEMBERSHIP BECAUSE FOR EXAMPLE
IF A COMMITTEE CHAIR- IS NOT
ABLE TO PHYSICALLY BE HERE TO
PRESIDE OVER COMMITTEE WE NEED
TO BE ABLE TO PIVOT QUICKLY.
THAT IS A PUBLIC HEALTH.
APPROACH AND IN TERMS OF
LIMITING. THE AMOUNT OF TIME
THAT WE CAN SPEAK THIS DOESN'T
LIMIT TO BE. I CAN STILL SPEAK
TO ANY BILL. BUT IT MEANS THAT
YOU CAN ACCESS SPEAK FOR
PERHAPS AS LONG AS YOU WANT AND
FRANKLY. ALL OF US IN THIS
PROFESSION EVERY SINGLE ONE OF
US. COULD PROBABLY USE
SOMETIMES SELF EDITING THAT'S
OF THE HUMAN NATURE WE
SOMETIMES GO ON A LITTLE BIT
TOO LONG. AND THE VAST MAJORITY
OF THINGS YOU CAN SAY IN THREE
MINUTES AND WE DON'T NEED AN
EXTENDED. PERIOD OF TIME
BENEFIT LIMITS THE AMOUNT OF
TIME THAT WE ARE TOGETHER. AND
A FOR A LITTLE MORE EFFICIENT
AND HOW WE DO THE BATES WITH
EVERYONE GETTING THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK. THAT'S
GOOD FROM A PUBLIC HEALTH
PERSPECTIVE AS WE GO THROUGH
THE VERY WORST PART. OF THIS
PANDEMIC. OVER EXPERIENCING NOW
IS WORSE THAN ANYTHING THAT
HAPPENED LAST YEAR. AND FINALLY
THIS IS DEMOCRATIC. BY LIMITING
THE AMOUNT OF TIME THAT PEOPLE
CAN SPEAK. THAT PREVENTS
FILIBUSTERING THAT PREVENTS
OTHER PEOPLE FROM PARTICIPATING
AND I CAN RESULT IN THE DEATH
OF BILLS NOT BECAUSE OF
DEMOCRACY. BUT BECAUSE SOMEONE
FILIBUSTER THESE ARE GOOD RULES
AND I SUPPORT THEM. THANK YOU
SENATOR WIENER SENATOR PAN.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
SENATORS- I TO RISE IN SUPPORT
OF PASSAGE OF- OF THESE RULES-
I DO APPRECIATE MY GOOD FRIEND
FROM TO HANNAH AND HIS HIS
LONGSTANDING EXPERIENCE HERE IN
THE LEGISLATURE AND HIS
PERSPECTIVE. AND AND HIS
REMARKS BUT I WOULD ALSO POINT
OUT AND I APPRECIATE MY GOOD
FRIEND FROM SAN FRANCISCO
POINTS OUT WE ARE WE ARE IN THE
MIDST OF A PANDEMIC AND
EMERGENCY A PANDEMIC WE HAVEN'T
SEEN. THE LIKES OF PROBABLY
SENSE. NINETEEN EIGHTEEN- AND-
I WOULD- AND SO CERTAINLY WE
HAVE TO CHANGE THE WAY WE DO
THINGS AND WE DID THAT LAST
YEAR AND I THINK MADE THE
CHANGES IN THE RULES THESE
RULES ARE BEFORE US IS TO
CODIFY THAT. I WOULD POINT OUT
ALL THE CHANGES WE'VE HAD TO
MAKE SO OF COURSE WE ARE SPREAD
OUT WE HAVE PEOPLE WHO ARE
PRODUCING ROUGHLY OR SPREAD OUT
HERE ON THE FLOOR. OF THE
WINDOWS ARE OPEN TO TRY TO
INCREASE VENTILATION RIGHT- WE
ARE FALLING PUBLIC HEALTH
GUIDELINES. AND THEIR- WE HAVE
GOOD NEWS AND BAD NEWS COMING
UP- GOOD NEWS IS THAT THERE
ARE- APPROVED VACCINES THAT ARE
SAFE AND EFFICACIOUS BUT WE
STILL HAVE TO GET THEM TO
PEOPLE. AND THE BAD NEWS IS
THAT THERE'S ACTUALLY A NEW
STRAIN OUT THERE THAT'S EVEN
MORE INFECTIOUS- THAN EVER
THAT'S THE READY HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES STARTED U. K.
AND- SO. IN ORDER FOR US TO
FUNCTION AS A SENATE WE HAVE TO
BE ABLE TO DO THAT SAFELY FOR
OURSELVES OUR STAFF THE MOST
IMPORTANT FOR THE PUBLIC AS
WELL. IN THESE ROLES. HELP US
TO DO THAT. THE OTHER THING IS
THAT- YEAH CERTAINLY GOING TO
LOOK AT THE LIMITATIONS ON
DEBATE HERE ON THE FLOOR AND
HE'S A BIT OF A TRADE OFF.
RIGHT I THINK WE WANNA BE SURE
EVERYONE'S ABLE TO SAY- MAKE
THE POINTS THEY WANT TO MAKE.
SAME TIME THE LONGER WE SPEND
TOGETHER. IN THIS CHAMBER AND I
LOVE ALL OF YOU. I LOVE TO
SPEND MORE TIME WITH YOU BUT
IT'S ACTUALLY UNFORTUNATELY
EVERY. THE LONGER IT DRAGS OUT.
ALONG WE SPEND EACH OTHER THE
HIGHER THE RISK IS THAT'S WHAT
WE HAVE THE WINDOWS OPEN. AND
SO I HOPE THAT WE WILL GET TO A
PLACE WHERE- WE DON'T NEED TO
WORRY ABOUT THIS VIRUS ANYMORE
AND WE DON'T HAVE TO PUT THESE
LIMITATIONS ON. BUT FRANKLY AS-
THE PHYSICIAN HERE IN THE
CHAMBER AND SOMEONE WHO HAS A
PUBLIC HEALTH BACKGROUND. I DO
VIEW THAT THESE RULES ARE
IMPORTANT RESPONSE TO TRYING TO
KEEP. US SAFE. SO WITH THAT- I
URGE AN AYE VOTE ON THE RULES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CENTER PAN
SIGNAL FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR. THE CENTER
WILL GO RIGHT BACK TO YOU
SENATOR BATES WERE YOU TRYING
TO RAISE YOUR HAND. I YES CAN
YOU HEAR ME WE CAN BORROW.
THANK YOU STATE YOUR NAME AND
PROCEED I SAID IT SHOULD BE
SENATE DISTRICT THIRTY SIX YES
MY- RAISE YOUR HAND ICON IS NOT
WORKING ON MY COMPUTER AT THE
MOMENT I JUST WANTED TO
UNDERSCORE- THE REQUESTED BY MY-
COLLEAGUES FRIENDS- THE CENTRAL
VALLEY OF. REGARDING PUTTING IT
OVER I JUST WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
TRYING TO TWO OR THREE DAYS
OBVIOUSLY BASED ON THE COMMENTS
THAT HAVE BEEN MADE BY MY
DEMOCRAT COLLEAGUES. THEY
PROBABLY HAD MAYBE MORE
ADVANCED BRIEFING ON WHAT IS
REALLY CONTINUE TO NEEDS THEY
DON'T APPEAR TO BE- THAT
RESTRICTIVE BUT I THINK IN
TERMS OF GOING FORWARD IN
UNITY. A LOT OF DISCUSSION
ABOUT THAT THESE DAYS I DON'T
SEE THE HARM IN IT TOO WHAT IS
IT. FOUR DAYS- AN OPPORTUNITY%
TO DIG INTO THAT AND MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE UNANIMOUS APPROVAL
OF SOMETHING THAT CHANGES ARE
FLOOR PROCESS SEES BUT THAT LET
PUTS EVERYBODY ON NOTICE THAT
THESE ARE THE RULES. AND ARE WE
NEED TO FOLLOW DOWN ON GIVING
YOU KNOW THE CITY THE SESSION
THE AND POTENTIAL LIMITING OF
THE SECTION THE OF THE PANDEMIC
DOESN'T COME UNDER GREATER
CONTROL CAN I SPEAK ABOUT THAT
BECAUSE IT'S NOT PLAN FOR THOSE
OF US WHO HAVE TO ACCOMMODATE.
NOT TO BE PART OF THAT THAT WE
ALL HAVE OUR ISSUES ARE. MAINLY
FOCUSED ON KEEPING OUR FAMILIES
SAFE SO I WOULD URGE US TO
RECONSIDER- THE OF THE CONCERN
HAS BEEN EXPRESSED REGARDING IS
BASICALLY PLEASE GIVE ME A FEW
MORE DAYS. TO REALLY DIG INTO
THEIR SO I CAN BE WITH THE
MAJORITY AND SAY THIS WORKS FOR
ALL OF US. THAT WOULD BE MY
REQUEST THANK YOU. THANK CENTER
BATES. CENTER GROVE. I'M
THINKING OUT OF FOLLOW UP MY
CALLER COME IN FROM C. DIEGOAND SEVERAL CA THAT WERE MADE
ON THIS REALIZE THAT THE IN THE
SESSION WAS KIND OF. AND BUT I
THINK THAT POLICY SHOULD BE
VIGOROUSLY DEBATED IN
TRANSPARENCY SHOULD BE
AVAILABLE AND I THINK THAT EACH
ONE OF OUR CONSTITUENTS- WANT
TO HEAR US SPEAK AND DEBATE
THAT PARTICULAR BILLS
ESPECIALLY IF IT'S A SUBJECT
MATTER THAT IS VERY IMPORTANT
TO OUR CONSTITUENTS SO- THE
MANDATORY TO HAVE A
PARLIAMENTARY INQUIRY IF
POSSIBLE PLEASE PROCEED IT IS
IT OKAY- CAN WE HAVE A
PARLIAMENTARY INQUIRY AND WERE
WE ABLE TO MAKE A MOTION. TO
AND SET THIS ASIDE UNTIL FRIDAY
TO WE RECONVENE SO THAT MEMBERS
WHO DID JUST RECEIVE THIS I DID
RECEIVE IT ABOUT THE SAME TIME
I THE MY COLLEAGUES DID- ON THE
SIDE OF THE AISLE IS THERE A
WAY THAT WE CAN SET THIS ASIDE
UNTIL FRIDAY SO WE HAVE FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND GOTCHA. ONE
MOMENT THANK YOU.
CENTER GROVE
THE PRESIDENT PRO TEM THE
LEADER OF THE SENATE WOULD LIKE
THIS MEASURE TAKEN UP TODAY. SO
THAT WE CAN PROCEED FORWARD. AM
I APPRECIATE MY COLLEAGUE AND I
ENJOY WORKING WITH HER
COLLEAGUES THAT AND ALTHOUGH WE
I THINK WE HAVE A GREAT.
RELATIONSHIP WE DO OFTEN
DISAGREE AND SO I WOULD REQUEST
THAT- I WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A
MOTION TO TAKE THIS A- LIKE A
VOTE ON IT- ON FRIDAY SO THAT
OUR- MEMBERS CAN HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO REVIEW THE
CONTENT OF THE NEW LEGISLATIVE
RULES. THANK YOU CENTER GROVE
CENTER HERTZBERG. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I MOVED TO LADY A
MOTION THE TABLE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SENATOR HERTZBERG SO
WE ARE GOING TO TAKE THE ROLE
CENTER GROVE IS ASKING FOR AN
AYE VOTE. SENATOR HERTZBERG IS
ASKING FOR A NO VOTE. MOTIONS
PUT ON THE TABLE. SO MEMBERS
REMOTELY WE WILL GET TO YOU
AFTER WE DO THE FLOOR VOTE
AGAIN CENTER GROVE'S ASKING FOR
AN AYE VOTE SENATOR HERTZBERG
IS ASKING SORRY CENTER GROVE IS
ASKING FOR A- NO VOTE CENTER
HERTZBERG IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE TO LAY THE MOTION ON THE
TABLE. BEN SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS I BAKER. ONE
HI PORGES NO BRADFORD I
CABALLERO I CORTESE HI SALLY.
NO DODD. FIVE TORONTO I EGGMAN
I GROWTH. NO HERTZBERG. I HUESO.
HURTADO JONES. NO LAYARD I
LEYVA I MCGUIRE I MELINDA'S MAN.
FIVE NEWMAN I NIELSEN. NO A
CHIRLA VOGUE. NO HAN I
PORTANTINO I. ROSS I RUBIO I
SKINNER HI AMBERG I Y. CASKEY I
WIENER I WILK. NOW MEMBERS WE
WILL NOT GOING TO A REMOTE
MEMBERS THEY'RE NOT VOTING
TODAY SO HIS TWENTY FOUR NO
SEVEN THE MOTION IS LAID ON THE
TABLE WE WILL NOW GO TO CENTER
ACTIONS FOR HER CLOSING REMARKS
MADAM PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND JUST FOR CONTEXT TO
THAT LAST VOTE THE REASON THE
DEMOCRATIC COLLEAGUES VOTED THE
WAY THEY DID IS THAT WE WOULD
BE UNABLE THIS WEEK TO MOVE
FORWARD TO THE NEXT ITEM OF
BUSINESS THE ESTABLISHMENT OF
THE RULES COMMITTEE AND
THEREFORE WE WOULD ALSO BE
UNABLE TO HAVE A BUDGET
COMMITTEE MEETING THIS WEK AS
ANTICIPATED. AS WELL AS- OUR
DAY POTENTIAL OF AN
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WE
HAVE TO APPROVE THE RULES AS I
UNDERSTAND IT- IN ORDER TO BE
ABLE TO PROCEED AND TO DO THE
WORK TO RESPOND TO A COUPLE OF
COMMENTS I WOULD- I WOULD SAY A
NUMBER OF THINGS ONE I TO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM FRESNO- THE
DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS IN THE
REPUBLICAN CAUCUS GOT THE RULES
AT EXACTLY THE SAME TIME TODAY-
AS WELL I WOULD DO I RESPOND TO
THE TO THE GENTLEMAN AND THE
DEAN. OF FROM TO HEMA AND SAY
THAT IN RESEARCHING WHAT TO DO
IN IN TIMES OF CRISIS AND
EMERGENCY WE'VE WE'VE GOT AT
LEAST FOUR EXAMPLES THAT WE
WERE ABLE TO ASK FOR FROM OUR
CLERK OF TIMES IN WHICH DEBATE
WAS LIMITED DOES THAT MEAN WE
SHOULD DO IT I JUST OUT OF HAND
WITHOUT SERIOUS CONVERSATION
AND DISCUSSION AND WE APPROVE
THESE RULES LAST YEAR IN MARCH
BECAUSE WE WERE I IN A POSITION
WHERE WE HAD TO MAKE SOME
DECISIONS AS A BODY AND BE ABLE
TO GO HOME TO OUR DISTRICTS
WHILE WE ADDRESSED WHAT TO DO.
IN A PANDEMIC SOMETHING WE HAD
NEVER EXPERIENCED THIS BODY HAD
NOT EXPERIENCE FOR MORE THAN A-
CENTURY. SO NONE OF THESE
DECISIONS ARE TAKEN LIGHTLY- IN
TERMS OF WHAT WE NEED TO DO- SO
I WOULD SAY THERE IS PRECEDENT
AND IT IS PRESIDENT THAT WE
SHOULD WEIGH HEAVILY. TO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA CLARITA-
IT IS TRUE WE TYPICALLY TAKE UP
THE RULES ON THE FIRST
ORGANIZATIONAL SESSION. MOST
EVERYTHING WE DID INCLUDING THE
CELEBRATE TORY NATURE. OF OUR
OF BEING ABLE TO RECOGNIZE NEW
MEMBERS THAT WORKED INCREDIBLY
HARD FOR TWO YEARS TO BE ABLE
TO JOIN THIS BODY. SO WE HAVE
LIMITED AND LIMITED AND LIMITED
TO THE BEST OF OUR ABILITY
ABILITY TO MEET THE PUBLIC
HEALTH. CONCERNS EXPRESSED BY
MY COLLEAGUE THE DOCTOR FROM
SACRAMENTO. WE HAVE HAD TO MAKE
ADJUSTMENTS FOR AMONG OTHER
EMERGENCY SITUATIONS AT THE END
OF SESSION TWO YEARS AGO WHERE
WE HAD TO ADJUST HOW WE
CONDUCTED OUR BUSINESS TO BE
ABLE TO FINISH OUR BUSINESS
WHEN WE- I HAD THE INCIDENT IN
THE CHAMBER- THIS IS BEEN AN
INCREDIBLE COUPLE OF YEARS AND
I WOULD JUST. SAY ALSO IN
DECEMBER OUR ORGANIZATIONAL
SESSION OUT WE WERE IN THE
MIDST OF ALL A SEARCH. HERE WE
ARE TODAY WERE STILL IN THE
MIDST OF A SUPER SURGE IN WHICH
WE NEED TO CONDUCT BUSINESS.
AND LEAVE AT OUR PRIORITIES AS
I STATED IN OUR OPENING
COMMENTS HAVE EVERYTHING TO DO
WITH THE CRISIS. AND THE RESULT
OF THIS PANDEMIC AND CRISIS
THAT'S CALLED ECONOMIC
UNCERTAINTY OUTLINED BY THE
REPUBLICAN LEADER AS WELL AS MY
COMMENTS. SO I. FURTHER THE
RULES ARE THANK IT INCOME IN A
MERGING SECTION OF OUR RULES
ARE NOT THROUGHOUT THE RULES AS
IF WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO.
TO ACT IN THIS MANNER IN
PERPETUITY FAR FROM IT. AND ARE
I WOULD LOVE NOTHING MORE THAN
TO BE ABLE TO SAY THESE RULES
WILL BE IN EFFECT FROM THIS
STATE TO THIS STATE KNOWING
THAT THE PANDEMIC WAS DONE BUT
WE CANNOT SAY THAT. AND SO I
HAVE NO DOUBT IN MY MIND THAT
MY DEMOCRATIC AS WELL AS MY
REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES. ARE
GOING TO HOLD US ALL
ACCOUNTABLE TO ADJUSTING THE
SITUATION AS SOON AS WE
POSSIBLY CAN AND PEOPLE ARE
ABLE TO DO THEIR WORK SAFELY.
BECAUSE WE ALL VALUE DEBATE AND
DISCUSSION. SO MUCH SO THAT IN
THE RULES IT SAYS WE CAN
SUSPEND. THE RULES IF WE NEED
FURTHER DEBATE AS WE PROBABLY
AND MORE THAN LIKELY WILL NEED
TO DO ON A NUMBER OF ISSUES IN
WHICH- WE ALL COME AT IT FROM A
VERY DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE IN
THROUGH A DIFFERENT LENS. I
WOULD HOPE LASTLY. JUST TO SAY
THAT- THE RECORD. THAT I HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO PUT FORWARD. WHEN
MY- DURING MY TENURE IN THE
ASSEMBLY MY TENURE HERE SHOWS.
A THOUGHTFULNESS AND APPROACH
THAT SEEKS TO BALANCE THE
CONCERNS AND THE NEEDS THAT WE
NEED TO DO WITH THE RESPECT
THAT I HAVE FOR EVERY SINGLE
COLLEAGUE IN THIS ROOM.
REGARDLESS OF WHERE YOU LIVE
REGARDLESS OF YOUR POLITICAL
PARTY REGARDLESS OF YOUR
PHILOSOPHICAL VIEWS. WE HAVE
WORK TO DO COLLECTIVELY. AND I
WOULD HOPE THAT PEOPLE I KNOW
ME ENOUGH ALL IN THE APPROACH I
TAKE TO UNDERSTAND. THAT I'M
NOT TRYING TO LIMIT SOMEONE'S
ABILITY TO REPRESENT THEIR
CONSTITUENTS FAR FROM IT AS
REFERENCE BY. I THE SENATOR
FROM LOS ANGELES WHO WAS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY- WE HAVE
SOUGHT TO GIVE EVERYBODY A
VOICE. AND A REPEAT REPRESENT
YOUR CONSTITUENTS AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO DO THAT TODAY I
BELIEVE IT IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE PASS THESE
RULES SO THAT WE CAN GET ON
WITH THE WORK THAT WE NEED TO
DO. AND THAT WE ARE ABLE TO
ESTABLISH A RULES COMMITTEE SET
THE REST OF THE AGENDA FOR THIS
WEEK AND THEN LEAVE THE CHAMBER
SAFELY. I AND FOLLOW THE
PRECAUTIONS IN THE GUIDELINES
THAT THE CDC AND OTHERS HAVE
PUT INTO PLACE FROM PUBLIC
HEALTH. SO WITH THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK MY COLLEAGUES
TO SUPPORT S. R. THREE AND
ESTABLISHING ARE SENATE RULES
TODAY. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT THANK YOU SENATOR
ATKINS MEMBERS WILL BE MOST
VOTING BY ACCLAMATION ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR OF SENATE RESOLUTION.
THREE PLEASE SIGNIFY BY SAYING
HI- THOSE OPPOSED TO NOW- THE
EYES HAVE IT AND THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED THANK YOU MEMBERS.
MEMBERS WE ARE NOW GOING TO
MOVE TO RESOLUTION FOR BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG PAN SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE RESOLUTION
FOUR BY SENATOR HERTZBERG
RELATIVE TO THE ELECTION OF
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE ON RULES CENTER
HERTZBERG THANK YOU VERY MUCH
BETTER PRESIDENT RESULT
RESOLVED BY THE SENATE. BUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT THE
FOLLOWING MEMBERS ARE HEREBY
ELECTED MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON RULES. SENATOR
BATES SENATOR HERTZBERG CENTER
LAYERED AND CENTER WILK THAT'S
THE TEXT OF. SENATE RESOLUTION
FOR ESCRIBIR. THANK YOU CENTER
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING
THEM ON THE FLOOR I WILL GO TO
A REMOTE PARTICIPATING
SENATORS. I DO NOT SEE ANY
HANFORD NOR ANY MICROPHONES OFF.
SO WITHOUT MEMBERS WE WILL
AGAIN VOTE BY ACCLAMATION ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR OF RESOLUTION
FOR SIGNIFY BY SAYING AYE.
THOSE OPPOSED NO. THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED MEMBERS
IF THERE IS NO OTHER BUSINESS
CENTER ATKINS THE DESK IS CLEAR
MADAM PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO
MUCH COLLEAGUES I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT YOU REMEMBER OUR NEXT
FLOOR SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR
FRIDAY FRIDAY NOT THURSDAY
FRIDAY JANUARY FIFTEENTH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AT NINE AM AND I
WOULD JUST URGE MY OLLEAGUES
IF YOU HAVE QUESTIONS ABOUT ANY
OF THE- PRECAUTIONS IN
PROCEDURES AS WELL AS THE
TESTING PLEASE REACH OUT TO THE
SECRETARY OF THE SENATE. HI AS
SOON AS YOU CAN WHATEVER YOU
NEED I KNOW THAT SHE IS
STANDING READY TO MAKE SURE WE
HAVE ALL OF THE RESOURCES AND
INFORMATION WE NEED TO BE HERE
SAFELY WITHOUT MADAM OUR
PRESIDENT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR ATKINS THE SENATE WILL
BE IN RECESS UNTIL THREE THIRTY
AT WHICH TIME THE ADJOURNMENT
MOTION WILL BE MADE WE WILL
RECONVENE FRIDAY AT NINE AM
HAVE A GREAT DAY MEMBERS.